and welcome to three scary games lives
this is going to be a mispronounce title
because I said three scary game lives
instead of three scary games live we are
going to be playing three scary games
and we're gonna be talking and we're
gonna be scared and we're gonna be
spooked and also there's going to be a
very special surprise if we manage to
hit three three three three three I
didn't practice this intro at all I
don't think I'm supposed to do anything
live but yet here I am good morning good
Monday to everybody thank you so much
for joining me on this wonderful
auspicious Monday the weather is
beautiful
maybe wherever you may be where I am the
weather is delightful it's coming in at
a beautiful 62 degrees a nice brisk
morning a little bit of a long sleeve
weather going on there if you're feeling
fresh and we're gonna be hitting it hard
and hitting it heavy as soon as we can
and looks like we're sick in now well
we're sitting at eleven thousand likes
already but we're not gonna get into
that I'm not gonna sit around because
the first game that we're going to be
playing if you didn't judge by the
thumbnail correctly is a spongebob based
horror game called red mist warning this
game contains jump scares flashing
lights scary and disturbing content
that's that's why I'm here alright let's
see what we got red mist controls and
credits wast run collect all by Leo
shock all right I'm sure this will be oh
you guys can't see the game here we go
they're beautifully there's gonna go
beautifully this is gonna go beautifully
man slow down on the likes I'm not ready
for the special surprise yet guys gosh
wait until the end of the first game
before you'd make me blow this special
surprise load already alright play red
mist
on on 7th January on the January the 7th
2000 Squidward was found dead in his
house by his friends SpongeBob and
Patrick the Bikini Bottom police started
investigation but could not find any
evidence of a possible murderer and
assumed it was a suicide as the gun was
in one of Squidward's hands a few days
later SpongeBob and Patrick were
reported missing last seen entering
Squidward's house in the middle of the
night as the Bikini Bottom police
continued the investigations the secret
cellar door was unveiled in Squidward's
house he plays one of the police
officers of the Bikini Bottom police you
have to enter the cellar will you unveil
the truth well alright then oh good to
know
dude I thought I've known you would have
gotten to 33 thousand I would have
raised it three to three hundred and
thirty three thousand so don't make me
do that because I will do that yeah I'm
gonna do that maybe I'll raise it you
know it's always good to move the goal
posts before we get to it now that won't
raise it that'd be cheap that'd be
stupid alright fine you guys are gonna
get your special surprise but I'm gonna
finish this game first even if we get to
it alright who's there is anybody there
all right interesting
not even a run sound not even a walking
sound just gonna throw me into the
basement of oh I'm slow just gonna throw
me into the basement and do nothing to
me
my goodness that's some spooky music oh
cool
Squidward spongebob Patrick you down
here you down here my dudes you're down
here ooh oh wait no that's not good
that's a laugh I thought that was a
hammer or a pipe or a wrench now that's
SpongeBob's leg okay I recognize this
sock now okay well that's good all right
hi is this a clarinet oh I got an item
was I supposed to be picking up any
other item that's like the first time I
picked up because I didn't know that I
was supposed to be picking up anything
it's awfully quiet down here great
something's gonna be coming after me
when I'm picking up these items all
right two items good to go from me sound
another leg how many legs oh he was he
was he was well that's one two legs but
we know that spongebob reproduces by
budding so this is a knife I'm sorry
hello is that I'm sorry what was it oh
hi Roy
he was wrong oh wow that's a dead
spongebob
that is a dead oh look I think we got to
33333 likes wow thank you guys thank you
as soon as I'm done with this game I
will give you this special surprise and
you are just going to love it
you are going to absolutely love it it
is going to be so gosh-darn wonderful
that you guys won't even begin to
believe
ooh ooh that's creepy
ooh-hoo I don't like that
ooh boy howdy I don't like that squidy
warty SB 1 to 9 this is some containment
breach [ __ ] SB 1 to 9
why why why would we do that thing that
you just did why would we do that
why this is a dildo how it's a hat ok
hat SB 1 to 9 there's going great guys
this is going real there's going great
so good that this is going great
super good super good super good super
great very very good and very very great
very good and very great all right
what is that Patrick Patrick Patrick
I mean starfish or sea stars as their
properly known as that my why is my
flashlight off the curry sea stars as
their properly known can also reproduce
kind of by budding but you can cut a sea
star in half and it'll grow to see stars
percent sure why the Bikini Bottom
police all I knew is they handed out
balloons ooh a net God a net yay I did
not expect this to be as creepy as it is
but it's just a little bit done this
pookie side of things first
oh hi diddly ho neighbor how you diddly
doing okay anyway all right do it grab
the flashlight stop well you know I
wasn't doing anything but you know I'll
stop to flashlights you can't beat me
now squid [ __ ] I got nose flashlights
ooh what's this a note nope just another
item just another lovely lovely item
there anything back here that I should
actually be concerned about is there
absolutely nothing and it's a waste of
time to go back it's a waste of time to
go back here it's definitely a waste of
time to go back here all right good good
great good great great oh don't you
worry your pretty little heads everybody
at home you're gonna get your special
surprise oh you're gonna get your
special surprise all right you're gonna
eat your special surprise I never said
it'd be good but you're gonna get your
special surprise don't you worry oh
you're gonna get your special surprise
hmm
what do we got on the wall there what do
we got on the wall true truth is truth
is near truth is near guys you hear that
truth is near great truth so near truth
is near okay those are just cheap jump
scares
those are gmod horror map level jump
scares you shall not get me with those
I'm a big brave boy as we all know and
as we all agree right
I can't run very fast oh no oh no oh no
oh no escape ending was there more than
one ending I guess I didn't get all the
items was there like another item that I
didn't find what the hell what the heck
I might have to go back into that just
to find the other ending what the heck
what the heck e hell alright hand let me
lay I'm gonna get out real quick and I'm
just gonna look for to see if what
endings there okay there's the death
ending there's the escape ending which I
got there's the corrupted ending and
then there's SB one two nine ending
I don't I don't know there must have
been an item that I missed there must
have been something tucked away that I
missed but before we do that before we
do that I have to give you guys your
very special surprise your absolute
special surprise I'm going to delete a
video not all surprises are good some
surprises are unpleasant and most
importantly we don't always know when
these surprises are going to come and
even more importantly than that
sometimes the surprises can have
unintended consequences we never know
what's going to be rounding the next
corner much like horror games we don't
know what life is going to throw at us
and I have a game here now that played a
long time ago that pertains to the game
that we're playing right now everyone
thinks that everything is permanent the
internet I'm here to disagree because
this game that I played on February 23rd
2018 which was yesterday pretty close to
two years from now it's 3:00 a.m. at the
krusty krab I'm going to be deleting
this some of you have forgotten that
when this honest has been going on for
three months now which means that we are
a quarter of the way to the entire
channel of Amazonas being deleted some
of you have forgotten just how close we
are to the end of that so what I'm going
to do right now is I'm going to delete
this game because I can't and because
it's important to remember that
sometimes you need to let go
options deplete it and second there
three and at the Krusty Krab all right
no come on you [ __ ] what they put the
goddamn delete button I can't find the
goddamn delete button where the Frick is
the delete button where is it
everyone get rips in chat r.i.p and chat
rit right now
this shit's going bye-bye we're late
Bartman i need to go back to the old the
old i need to go back to the old studio
because this one obviously wants to hide
the content delete button oh I know all
of you I know all of you are gnashing
your teeth get big rip
big rip right here it is okay actions
all right this is it
[Music]
we've got classic YouTube studio 3m at
the krusty krab checked actions delete
gone
gone big riperoni big rip and a half
hate to see it go sad to see you leave
but that's the way it goes sometimes
sometimes you have to remember that not
everything is gonna stay around not me
YouTube not the Internet as we know it
everything changes
yes but nothing's permanent keep that in
mind
Lunas honest is gonna continue for a
long time so if you want to enjoy it you
have to enjoy it now but it's important
to learn to let go it'll make it hurt a
little less at the end now anyway let's
let's get back into the scoop all right
so great surprise am i right guys great
surprises okay so what we need to do is
we need to get to the SP one to nine
ending so there's got to be something in
here that I have not seen that I want to
see want to get to the end of it I want
to get to the end of it I want to get to
the end I want to get to the end all
right let's try this again so there's
gotta be there's got to be getting all
of the items right so somewhere hidden
must be another item I bet it'd be early
on because I didn't pick up a neckloop
game such an expert gamer here I'm such
an expert gamer I'm such an expert gamer
here I can't believe it oh yeah that
that video had about 5 million views on
it so that's 5 minute that was a 5
million view video that I just puffed
away into the ether goodbye farewell
gone forever and it's that simple it is
literally that simple it's it's one of
those things where you really should
embrace change holding on to things for
too long
makes you afraid to move forward in the
future it is to me very important to
learn that lesson maybe back here I bet
it would be all wait what I just see
bold and brash Oh bold and brash indeed
okay that was probably the only item
that was missing in this endeavor
because I got six of them so this much
mean this this much mean this must mean
unless there's like a hidden eighth item
which would be fitting but that must
mean that's got that's what's going to
get me to the end of this either the
true ending the secret ending or the
corrupted ending mmm interesting okay I
mean it's funny because there's not a
lot to this game it's pretty similar to
a lot of games that I've played in the
horror world where you know it's just
like go fetch items kind of like a
walking simulator see what happens
spooks jump out at you but you know at
some point the rest of people at some
point the recipe just kind of works it
does work it's a little spoopy it's like
you know that's why people like slasher
films all the time I still like it I
still like it
yeah riperoni riperoni riperoni riperoni
and cheese pepperoni oh yeah this this
was a good spook I have to admit this
was a quality spook right there I love
that
very scary very scary but SB one to nine
spongebob one to nine does that mean is
that referring to an episode wait is
that like an episode have there of
course there's been like 129 episodes of
Spongebob haven't there been yeah I bet
there have been all right I'll do I
gotta bump up the special surprise to
666666 Oh there'll be another special
surprise oh there will be another big
special surprise if you guys want to see
an even bigger even more special
surprise not really like if you want to
listen guys manipulating people into
liking videos is not usually my style
I'm always of the mind that if you enjoy
the game free enjoy the video you like
it I don't need that ask you to like
something because like that is like a
personal philosophy of mine there's a
lot of like incentives on YouTube is it
like right mini Jesus Christmas there's
like a lot of things that are like hey
get your audience engaged like tell him
to like it right away but if people if
you ask people to like a video at the
beginning of the video they don't know
what the video is [ __ ] about how do
they know if they actually like it how
do they know if they want to see more of
that video if they do just if they you
tell them to like at the beginning it
doesn't make any [ __ ] sense and I
still don't even know if the like button
actually does anything in the grand
scheme of things like who who even knows
but that's like I've always had that
philosophy I've had videos where I'm
like leave a like if you want but that's
always at the end and it's always I
don't really care one way or another
okay so I got all the items yeah moral
the story is if you actually enjoy the
video that's when you should like a
video not because someone asks you to do
it not because someone coerced you into
liking the video like you wanted to do
it the same thing I believe about the
subscription subscribe if you want to
subscribe not if you like we're told
reminded to subscribe you should
subscribe to a channel that you want to
see more of that's the point and that's
the point of the Bell which there's an
art there's an argument to be made about
the Bell and its validity like if you
subscribe in my mind it's well ok that's
happening I forgot about that I forgot
about that how can I forget about that I
don't know I can forget about that
forget about that okay so what did I
what did I get here oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
secret time secret time okay anyway more
other stories subscribe if you want to
see more . . i don't care
in the long run about that like a video
if you enjoyed it and you want to see
more of that type of content write down
write down whatever the hell this is
okay 5c w ft capital d i capital z9 z
capital is that a capital y ur a lot I
think that's a capital y looks big and
that's obviously Morse code good I
forgot one more school can someone help
me translate this Morse code it's
repeating is it six letters
it's just six it repeats on II know it's
not SOS I can't remember my goddamn
Morse code [ __ ] up I pull up a chair
I'm such an idiot yeah it repeats on E
you hear the e it's just easy single dot
the god I need to pull up like mspaint
or something
oh [ __ ] it won't freak okay I'll need to
I need to do the only two I'll just need
to pull up a note and then draw it
god I'm really [ __ ] this up okay dot
dot know the song it's six it is five
letters okay
c ec e CH e CH e CH he sees the
da-da-da-da-da w CH w da a ec h w eh c
wah-wah wet Wow what what what oh you've
gotta be kidding me Oh escape oh oh
where did I go wrong on that I didn't
even get an S in that escape ah
god I'm an idiot it's just stupid
alright so I got the corrupted ending is
that what I got what what what oh whoops
oh oops
well sorry nothing happened nothing
happened I went forward I got this that
was it sorry I took all right guys all
right okay I get it
listen I get it I get it I get it
I'm dumb I'm put to get I'm not a
professional streamer I'm not a
professional youtuber I get it I'm dumb
you know what maybe maybe [ __ ] do it
again you want you want another video
delete it I'll [ __ ] do it again do it
again
I'll do it again switch taken away huh
switch taken away huh you want
everything taken away huh
I don't try me try me I'll do it again
I'll do it again you know yeah I will I
will what if we get to six thousand six
are sixty six thousand six hundred and
sixty-six likes huh what's gonna get
what's gonna get your phone gets deleted
at a hundred thousand likes where if we
get this bad boy to a hundred thousand
like I'll delete your existence we're
gonna you'll be gone Li snap then oh
snap you out of into dust try me
good to a hundred thousand like see what
happens Oh I'll punish you good yeah you
think you can just walk in here and you
think you can like a video of mine huh
let me bring the echo and you think that
you can just walk in here into one of my
videos and you think that you can just
like it oh no not on my watch no way no
Jose you ain't Jose you ain't no way and
you ain't gonna exist after I die no
snap you into oblivion so try me I ain't
no professional streamer I'm a
professional Thanos so try I'm getting a
little Yancey here but try me try me oh
I'll show you I'll show you how it do oh
I'll show you try me you want try me ah
no you know what try me just yeah I dare
ya I dare you okay I dare you I dare ya
okay anyway sir alright alright so I'm
thinking that must have said I must I
need to do hit the escape button I bet
that's what that is
the only reason why it would be escape I
got ec h w AE I thought dr. dot ah it
would to see no oh that the dot dot the
dot that was it that adopted is that
what is that no was it dad - Tata
because s is that ideals me oh I go ah
hey stupid
oh I stupid oh I go I go
I
what's a mochi what's stupid I forget
what's stupid this is great I'm stupid
I've gone back in my gosh here's the
game we're going for it
around three baby we got this the puzzle
is gonna be solved and you guys are
gonna be obliterated into oblivion just
try me huh just I dare you you don't
have the guts to subscribe to my channel
you don't even have the hood Spa to be
able to subscribe to my channel
I need hoods but you need to have at
least hood spa of this height to be able
to subscribe to my channel and oh I'm
sorry you are lacking the hood spud to
be able to subscribe so just go get out
you don't even deserve to be here you
don't have loot spot so don't even try
you ain't got the hoot spa what's balls
in Korean what's testicles in Korean
someone please tell me what testicles is
in Korean and this is this is very
important you got it you can trust me
what's testicles in cream mmm what's
testicles in Korean someone please tell
me got it
Siri hey Siri what's testicles in Korean
I came out translated into Korean yet
well you're frickin useless god damnit
Siri why can't you do anything alright
whatever I'm gonna get this and then
we're good there I'm amazing
look you can't compliment your way into
earning a subscription to my channel you
can't just compliment me do a super chat
and then think that you're allowed to
subscribe to my channel it's a very
elite club that we have here and I'm
just sorry you don't make the cut
I'm sorry where's your hood spa this is
where my hoods but is this is where your
hood spa is so just don't even bother
don't even bother trying to subscribe to
my channel cuz you cannot you cannot you
can't do it you cannot even
motely come close to getting to near
enough hood spa
what's it well it's going too fast ah
it's too fast it's too fast you're
talking too fast I can't read Korean
that quickly I can't read it whatever
got you all right everybody stop
chatting for two seconds everybody stop
don't know jack no chat no chat for two
seconds your hood spot will increase
will double if you don't check for two
seconds unless you're speaking Korean
right now are you guys in your reverse
psychology god damn it if you don't
think you don't have the hot spa you
don't have that poodle go on is it go
hon go hon or poodle Budda Budda Budda
go hon go hon do that what are you
making me say what are you making me say
am i saying a slur in Korean right now
how dare you you think you can trick me
I am - turning dr. Cayle you can't trick
me okay
you can't trick me I know I'm too smart
for you I know you're making me say
things that are just you you think you
think you think that I don't know you're
up - no way Jose no Jose no way no way
Jose I missed an item didn't I
I miss oh no I didn't okay I'm good
no way Jose are you are you telling me
that testicle in Korean is food al like
ball
every time every time without every
goddamn time every goddamn time okay are
you telling me are you telling me yeah
you're not telling me stop okay so I bet
this is the answer I bet what it is is
you get here you get two there you don't
go too far for it you hit escape before
you get cold up dude okay all right
don't don't even don't I'm not gonna
fall for it you know what you know what
you know what you know what those of you
who were with me in that and backed me
up and know that you are also total kale
you are also smart you're smart you
don't okay okay that's it that's
something to do if I'm if okay here it
pulls politeness in Korean if I'm
talking to you as the audience do I
speak to you with in a polite way do I
speak to you in a newscaster way how do
I speak to you I don't know
I don't know
I don't know okay so what we're gonna do
now is I'm gonna get close and I'm gonna
hit escape as soon as I hear that OOP
[Music]
what the Freak wait what all it does is
make my mouse appear maybe it means I
just need to turn around and go you know
what I'm gonna oh that's weird
well how do I wait a minute wait a
minute if that's not it time to do the
age-old trick of looking up what other
people have done
oh boy you go give me the secret ending
give me the secret goody goody goody
no you oh my god have no one gotten the
secret ending oh my god known as oh no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
okay it's fine cuz we're smart you know
we are we're big brains
we're big brains we're big brains we are
big brains collectively we're big brains
and we can solve this you know why
because we are big brain
I'm not fapping I'm stimulating my big
bring this which is part of my biceps
what's your just [ __ ] phenomenal so
that's how we do it escape its watch I
knew it I knew that wasn't an ass you
[ __ ] who I knew I was right you guys
made me think I was an idiot you guys
made me think I was dumb how dare you
how dare you how dare you how dare you
watch okay watch I have my watch here it
is an Apple watch I love this my husband
levels are dropping guys my husband
officer all right so what watch mean
watch oh wait wait wait
of course of course of course wait wait
okay that that that's a code to a video
I bet I'm willing to bet that's that's a
code to a video hang on pan and that's a
code to a video that's definitely a code
to a video so if I go to like that's so
a code to a video I bet YouTube video
definitely 5c w ft d z 9z y oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
there she is so there's three cans there
are three cans
the three cans in the game we are
[ __ ] big brain mode we are in big
brain mode guys we have our spa levels
are increasing every single second our
hoods bottles are bigger than they've
ever been guys how does it feel to have
this much foot spa how does it feel how
does it feel how does it feel it better
feel good because Wiis about to solve
the mystery okay
armed with this knowledge armed with
this knowledge I'm gonna put this over
here so I can see where these were so
we've got decent decent and these okay
cool so why I've been guessing I'm
guessing whatever blood blood low okay
so I'm guessing what's gonna happen this
is what happened last time that you guys
didn't see and then that happened but
that's fine the truth is near got it
okay got it okay so get here get here
big brain brain oh my god spot guys you
are about to earn the right to subscribe
to my channel you guys are about to earn
it you guys have not earned it yet I
want to be very clear you were not
earned it yet you are you're getting
close the hood spot is rising but do not
subscribe you do not earn the right you
have not earned the right not yet not
yet okay so what we need what we need
well we need hang on and ham so what
we're gonna do is I'm gonna put this I'm
gonna put this right there okay so now
we can flip back and forth between this
okay the first one is bottom right of a
shelf first ones bottom right of a shelf
first ones like middle with a box there
okay let's I'm assuming that these are
gonna be in some kind of an order so as
I can see there's nothing here on these
shelves that would have that so it's
gotta be a head this is it guys this is
it
this is it whoo-hoo be careful about
those lights we're about to hit 69 K and
that would just be that would be too
crisp we can't have that we cannot have
that we cannot have that can not allow
cannot have it not allowed absolutely
unalloyed okay so there's nothing here
there's no kin of who hash oh that looks
like a winner baby okay let's just
evaluate oh yeah oh that's the winner
that's the winner right there okay so we
got a confirmatory noise I'm not sure
that's exactly what should have happened
but I got it I'm also gonna collect the
items just in case I don't know if that
affects it in any way I don't know okay
there they were all on the bottom shelf
so the next one is buy a box so that's
good okay
buy a box good to know good to know good
to know good to know you're not gonna
run too much just in case I'm gonna have
to make a mad dash for it but this is it
ladies and gentlemen and everything in
between we are about to enhance our
loads because I feel it oh I feel it I
think we all feel it we all know we all
feel oh I miss 69 Oh God I wasn't
looking all right we got a rounded okay
we got to go to a hundred thousand we
got to go to a hundred thousand
sixty-nine because I missed I missed 69
please just I never asked for likes but
if you could just ignore the fact that
the title of this video special surprise
guys I'd never asked for but we got to
get to 169,000 because I missed it it
was gone
so we got to go back we got to go to 6-9
6-9 6-9 we got there six hundred ninety
six thousand six hundred and ninety six
or six hundred ninety six thousand nine
hundred and sixty nine likes cuz
otherwise I'll like you there'll be
they'll just will be no point like I I
just I can't fathom the life where I
didn't wasn't able to see it guys please
let's do I like your enthusiasm guys I
like your enthusiasm your dues it's good
you're in here yeah cold coffee mm-hmm
it tastes better because it's in one of
Amy's mugs
okay all right Patrick who cares who
cares Pat okay definitely not that one
because it was on a lower shelf it most
certainly was on a lower shelf that's
for certain
I think yeah baby oh yeah I heard
another confirmatory noise okay so the
last one is from the back seeing one of
those I think I know where that is I
think I know it's not in here definitely
not but it is oh yeah oh yeah I'm gonna
get all the items before I go collect
that last one but we are about to get to
the truth oh we're about to get to the
truth also thank you to everybody that's
become a member during the stream every
frickin time thank you to everybody
that's become a member during the stream
ordinarily we do member live streams on
Monday but we're doing this one instead
for a benefit everybody so thank you so
much for being a member and supporting
me and allowing me to be able to do the
videos that I have been doing okay so
the puzzle here is which box is it right
okay so oh oh no it's this one because
it's got the two above it it's
definitely this one
we did it ladies and gentlemen we are
about to solve the mystery of SB one to
nine
I will not be stopped sir I will not be
stopped we have got this we are winning
this we are killing this we are
dominating this buoy hot spots to be
able to solve this mystery and no one
not a soul not a squiddy not a starfish
and no sponge will be able to annihilate
our hoods bah we have this in it to win
it I'm spitting profusely ooh ha
not at all squid boy all right you're
gonna do your thing and you do your
things Whitman oh yeah he's doing his
thing
okay okay okay okay all right okay
Oh SB one two nine when you entered SB
one two nine you were teleported on the
day of this Squidward assassination you
caught mr. Krabs in the act when he
tried to shoot Squidward you overpowered
and arrested mr. Krabs he was sentenced
to prison for attempted murder for 25
years to be continued it was mr. Krabs
everybody was mr. Krabs we did it
our what's this enormous oh my god
you've all earned the right to subscribe
everyone here has earned the right
congratulations
[Laughter]
Wow what a simple game but man I'd love
a good puzzle I love a puzzle
hello I love a puzzle I love a puzzle
and I feel like we did that all together
I feel like we did that all together oh
man good stuff good stuff good stuff
good stuff but it's not over No
you think I didn't notice you think I
didn't notice what you did huh you think
he could hide your sins from me no I
know I know
I know you like this video how dare you
how dare you you have the gall to just
walk in to my home and it's like a video
are you kidding me the goal no how dare
you dare you
I will Rico horrible vengeance on you
you will see pain unlike any other hi
I'll find you and I will make you suffer
for what you've done
okay anyway met in that next game next
next game let's go on guys we're having
fun here this is great
it's good stuff it's good stuff good
stuff really good stuff guys really good
stuff whoa all right next game is ooh
next game is a little loud
next game is mortuary assistant alright
let's give it a go shall we
hello hi Valerie its Raymond I know it's
late and I'm really sorry but I have a
huge favor to ask you I delete pick up
over at sacred waters and I just started
the embalming maybe 20 minutes ago but I
have a family emergency I need to leave
the office for would you be able to come
in and finish it up just a body like I
was elbow deep in this body come in
finish it up I mean sure but I haven't
done on one alone yet are you sure
that'd be okay I'll be fine you've been
doing a great job and I'll leave a
checklist for you just in case I took
care of some of the prep work already I
really appreciate it thank you thank you
pal all right I'll be there in just a
moment great thank you so much I'll see
you tomorrow all right cool all right
cool all right kick it cool is this a
checklist oh look at clipboard
all right I've already checked the
vitals bathed the body and set the face
[Music]
embalming procedure you know what you're
doing by now but just in case here's a
list embalming procedure checklist wear
coat and gloves I didn't bring the tools
out yet so bring tubing syringes scalpel
and trocars to the side table create the
embalming mixture in the machine
formaldehyde glutaraldehyde
glutaraldehyde ethanol create an
incision in the carotid artery and
jugular vein insert fluid into tube
there flue tube into artery insert
drainage tube into vein cavity embalming
using trocar insert the multiple
locations to relieve gas buildup and
balm moisturizer makeup dress reviewing
uh so this is like a legit it is like a
legit I'm about to go through the
process of embalming a body that my
grandma okay oh my
you set the face I don't know what that
means
oh my oh my okay gloves
I'm usually a large but I'll take a
medium I guess alright gloves see my
checklist coat coat need cold let's
close the door just in case yeah it's a
good close okay alright okay cool good
check swing to [ __ ] hold to Bosh a
packing sponge
trocars what's is this a trocar do you
know what a trocar is okay good good
talk Oh drainage what is this oh my I'm
not qualified for this okay blue tear
old old hide I need a side table or
something I don't I don't have one oh
here it is okay alright dump this bad
boy in okay never mind don't dump that
bad boy in I raped syringes tubing
scalpel what's in here nothing it's
nothing
it's death Oh smooth scalpels
how do I open you can I open you huh
help
Oh guys help
affiliates bodies gonna get up in any
second now all right oh right here all
right
scalpel interesting well wow that's good
spook I've never seen something like
that that's good one
good great ah but not if what I'm doing
here oh it's gone okay go thank you I
need to see tubing what it was you two
being okay tubing tube
Frick Frick Frick all right cool
formaldehyde glutaraldehyde we'll get
your artificial tissue builder that's
now what I need maybe it is I don't know
all right
formality well we're why for what
purpose is this the formality well d oh
there it is got it
okay all right all right smile on your
face wait wait wait wait wait okay wait
wait wait kind of smiling smile you know
I'm here
I know you sure do who doesn't know me
I'm markiplier baby come on oh wow hey
[Laughter]
okay cool I would like to think that the
entrance into hell is a giant gaping
butthole but I can't read this no I
don't think so that'd be a bad idea if
you were to come in here I've got
scalpels I've got ethanol you you you're
[ __ ] on six different dimensions buddy
if you think that I all right you know
who's there oh there you are grandma all
right good grandma grandma grandma
grandma okay I guess I'm in here now I
can't move
ha oh no none of that none of that is
necessary to out a half John three
quarters
we might do it oh wait oh no did it bug
or something am I supposed to be able to
move oh no oh no guys
oh no I can't move no not like this guys
no please
no I why do I always break games it's
cuz I close the door isn't it it's
because I closed the door at first oh
come on please oh no I bet there's a
nice note on here all right fine dammit
God god damn God every time every time I
break my speed through we'll get back to
where I was I'm not gonna close the door
again like a maybe whatever a ninny is
I'm gonna get in there I'm gonna be a
badass and I'm just going to muscle my
way through you know sometimes I realize
that what my friends make fun of me go
like Oh Morgan more like we see them
doing it I'm like oh yeah okay I never
do that and I realize now I do that a
lot I do that a whole heck of a lot okay
alright like the candle maybe not light
let's not light the candle I don't even
want to look at the candle alright
alright Grammy Graham Graham Graham ster
give me this okay nevermind need to put
on my coat and gloves forgot about that
medium
cold right speed run baby speed run
belly all right right there just get
died in there oh yeah speed run baby run
baby speed run speed speed if we need
for speed baby all right how we doing
okay good that's where that comes in
great
all right why it's fine
speed run baby speed run speed run baby
and ethanol and then I need to make a
decision okay hey how you doing
yes I do oh it doesn't open right away
all right cool
well all right
can I get it can i what if I arm myself
of this scalpel what if I arm myself
with a scalpel
nope okay no defending myself ah yeah
hey I'm here now
hi Grammy hello oh yeah it's a good
stuff that's the good stuff that's where
we love to see that's what I love to see
actually that's that's what I
that was the end of the game
go to what what why what why why why why
why why why
all right cool good glad I played
through that again I mean good game dark
stone digital I like that that wasn't
very cool but goddamn
god dammit god dammit okay all right
cool
third gun final game third and final
game coming up dig dig dig dig
here comes shoot you can't believe who
could believe it no one can believe it
no one can believe it alright so this
one's called paranoid no don't turn on
steamvr oh yeah you know what else I
should do I should change the title I
guess it's no longer needs to be special
surprise because the special surprise
has already happened yeah leave that
there yeah it's good
that's good all right so now we maybe
there's a special surprise at 100k but
you already know what it is there's
gonna be gonna be fan of snapped out of
existence so this one's called paranoid
playable teaser I don't know if this has
anything to do with Pete Petey awakened
by the cries of a woman the man came out
of the apartment
before he comes back someone want to
help there we go alright
hello open oh oh locked okay someone's
really wailing the door is locked she
needs help
the janitor is downstairs he will help
me break the door before the other guy
comes back oh you could knock you you
could like knock how about try going up
first
well this moderately unsettling also my
my silhouette is moderately unsettling
[Music]
the yani tour I am do i repair the clock
all right okay is it broken
oh yeah it's broken all right look at
that face mmm all right cool great
[Music]
great good stuff glad I live here glad I
picked this apartment to live in all
right good stuff all right good stuff
good good good stuff good stuff in
things what what what what why but weird
but where else would I go where do I
where would I go where should I go Oh
[Music]
I'm back baby baby I'm back I'm on a
roll I'm back baby don't know why I
don't try the elevator and back baby
okay I don't know where I'm going on
back baby
baby I'm back American groom back baby
guys I don't know what the hell is
happening here like I mean by design I
guess I don't know what the hell is
happening here but also throwing me off
frills giving me the really giving me
the business and I don't know what the
business is but business is good
apparently that guy who does everything
I know about that guy that guy a lot of
okay good talk thanks dude whoever you
are guitar
great good can I actually go down here
now or am I just gonna be looping back
and forth I'm gonna be doing the looping
back and forth dance well I can't see
all right cool good ain't afraid no
ghosts I had afraid no ghosts
where'd this closet come from I am
afraid of closets or wardrobes or
boudoir
okay all right and back up I go you all
right ain't good for talking we're
communicating we're on the same
wavelength guys mm can't Oh can't save
her oh I guess I can't all right cool oh
that is ballet beautiful posing
beautiful beautiful indeed beautiful
beautiful beautiful beautiful big
beautiful bouncing boobies oh right the
way is open for me the way is open
I'm gonna try this door first of course
because why wouldn't I because that
seems like a logical thing to do because
I definitely would do that all right try
it and it goes nowhere so I'm gonna keep
going down this hallway hey considering
I can't save her I'm just gonna try to
go to okay I'm gonna go to the grocery
store I'm gonna ignore all the weird
shadowy demons I'm just gonna ignore all
the weird
great great stuff good stuff all right
we're good hearts still going how you
guys doing you're good you're good
you're good home you could in tucked in
your bed all safe and sound well I have
to deal with this nonsense it's
ridiculous oh I have a hand oh I have a
body oh I have a chest Oh who's knock
knock knocking on my chamber door I
don't live in an apartment I live in the
hallway oh man oh no oh oh no oh no oh
no oh oh I see you oh no I see you okay
I know you're there and I'm I'm coming
for you yeah oh my god
oh I bet that's pride copyright blimp
okay um all right good
hey that was spicy spicy spicy that was
spicy I love that that was cool
fairy vise very spicy spicy spicy and
also you know what I regret changing the
name of uh I regret changing the name of
it cuz you know that this is a special
surprise know the name of it cuz if
there was a special surprise that just
so people know what this was all about
alright okay cool good hey thank you
guys so much for joining me for this day
of scary games um that was fun I got a
lot of writing to do this week I've got
a lot this week is basically gonna be
just writing I've got a lot of writing
to do I've got a lot of stuff to do but
there's some cool stuff planned if you
have not checked out Oona's honest yet
or in a while know that the time is
always running out I didn't think we
would get to three months this quickly
but boy howdy we have and that means
there's only less than nine months to go
before unas honest is gone so if you
haven't checked it out check it out
check out the merch got new honest sir
version of the founders merch but thank
you everybody so much for watching you
did not get to a hundred thousand likes
which means that you have been saved
from the fan oh snap
congratulations you know exactly what
it's all about but I have to mosey and I
will nosey on out this way and I will
get to writing today and I will get a
lot of stuff done in a lot of work done
I got a I got to get it all written
or the end of the week but I will get it
done and then there will be videos
returning to normal form starting
tomorrow
that's a guarantee it's a markiplier
problems right there ciao so thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
enjoyed the video if you enjoyed this
experience leave a like if you want to
see more videos from me and only if you
want to see more videos from me
subscribe and ring the bell to be
notified of when because asking in any
other capacity seems a little silly if
you ask me but no one else is asking me
because I don't know how to be a proper
eye shadow me either way thank you all
so much for watching take care of
yourselves take care of each other and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye bye guys